so welcome i think is um 3 30 now so
i'm going to start the talk so the talk
will be about what's new in version 10
about the graphic
like networks
i didn't notice the lights
thanks
okay
so as you all know we introduced graph
in version 8 so you know
graph objects start to be the first
class citizen in mathematica and global
form language if you put it that way
during version 8 and
so essentially the approach was to do
provide tools for our functionality for
modeling analyzing and synthetizing
graphs essentially our networks in
general
so we introduced about 150 functions so
that was a huge amount of work a lot of
new functionalities
and in version nine
we went one step further so that was you
know version eight was essentially put
the framework in place
so in version nine we tried to do a
vertical and the vertical we picked was
social network it was a whole topic at
the time or still somehow
so we introduced a couple of functions
about social network analysis centrality
and such
and we enhanced the modeling and
analysis aspect in graph a network
so and
in general the frameworks you know show
that it's solely done it you know
people you can build on top of it so
during version 10 we decided essentially
to
you know instead of going vertically
kind of going back horizontally and try
to enhance it more
by introducing actually more
functionality for modeling
more functionality for analysing and you
know
specific domain application
cases so is essentially that part i'm
going to talk about you know how we
enhance the modeling and the analysis
but as you know i want to point out from
the start you see that the number of
functionality the number of functions we
introduced between two those three
versions actually dropped
but in behind the scene the scope
actually increased and actually is what
i will try to show you that the system
get more smarter
and you get more
you know more power to actually from the
same set of functions you can actually
do more
so
for version 10
you know we did a framework wide support
of multi-graph and mix graph
and i will show how we did actually is
that transparently and quite easily for
you to just use
you know without actually modifying our
workflow
and the next thing we actually did is
we did a 3d graph visualization which
was a request from several users since
we already have 3d visualization in
mathematica so that was one step close
enough to get
but also that's required a lot of work
which kind of shows
the scope and what we did
and as usual we introduced new
capability
you know there's for sure several areas
you know we haven't covered in earlier
versions so we decided to push and
actually add more functionality in that
direction
and as usual we like to enhance the
performance make it faster and make it
better for you and make it easier so we
improve the performance and usability of
the functionality and i hopefully kind
of show some of those and some people
you know if you actually use graph more
often you actually probably already
noticed that it get more fluid the way
you actually use graphs
so
let's start with um
one of the main functionality which is
in tradition of graph you know and the
fact that we build mixed graph and multi
graph in the system so what is the mixed
graph a multi graph i will start there
so it's essentially a graph which has
multiple edges
oh
you'll break my alignment and i will
blame you
okay
so essentially we decided we have to
introduce multigraph so essentially as
you know
least some people will not agree with me
but the world is not just based on
sample graph you know directed and
directed if you think about the road
network
you know you should usually have one
lane
two lanes you know
multiple edges so to actually model such
a network
you need
multi-graph or mixed graph or both
actually
for sure you can do a lot of work by
just you know dealing with you know the
sample graph but that require a lot of
work so what we did is that we tried to
actually build multigraph and mix graph
behind the scene for you
and that whole work which took months
and complex enough as we try to show we
just resume in set of three functions
so the first thing is that how will you
construct a milk a
multigraph
if i manage to find my case it's here i
thank you
so we just use the same constructor we
have graph is a constructor and
representation of the object so if you
just you know
specify the same edge twice you get the
mixed valve and you just work
automatically the auto visualization is
there
you display like any other graph you can
take it and you can do all the
computation
from it oops
and you get the results and hopefully it
have four edges
so it works as
the one you have since version 8 but you
just have
more capability essentially the
constructor talking about gap
and the other function we also provided
is a q function just to check
that your graph is immutable for mixed
curves essentially
so for multi-graph sorry for mixed graph
as you can guess
if you take the same constructor you
give them you give it a directed edge
and on the right edge you get a mix
graph so this is
done directed edge this is directed one
and
as earlier you can just manipulate it as
anything else
so in background we do the work for you
we have a more optimized representation
for those graphs
every function essentially is duplicate
in term of algorithm and what is behind
we implemented new functionality for
each function
so for the set of
oops
so this is just a plot of the set of all
the functions we have
which is roughly about more than 200 for
each of them we have to work and
implement behind the scene functionality
for you so we haven't added
200 more functions for you which work
for multicultural mixed calf
but we did that just by enhancing the
existing functionality
and the other thing i'd like to show
actually um let's see find us
so if you take for example in the
documentation and you probably will
notice it
oh what
let me
make it slightly bigger
so when you look at the documentation in
mathematica and you just oh this is new
not interesting let's see um
find shortest
part
so for example for the old function
if you click on update it you see
down here what we just added
you know all that enhancement work and
making the whole system smart in the
documentation you just resume with one
line so essentially we say that function
work for on the right graph directed
graph weighted graph mixed graph
and multi graph
and you can imagine each
type of graph you know have probably his
own algorithm and his own
automation behind the scene
so and in short this is the way we
introduce that whole framework
and currently mathematic is actually the
only system
as far as i know which actually can
support all these types of graphs
so
now how
so let's see
so that's essentially what i will talk
about you know
ma um
sorry multigraph a mix graph there will
be a talk
friday about advanced you know workshop
on you know
advanced graph graph theory and such a
thing so if you want to actually
understand the details
how we implement it and how you you know
to use your you know your functionality
to make it more efficient
you know you can attend that talk so now
i just present in short what we provided
and just to show also you know the power
of the functionality as well as the
design you put in place
you know most of you know the you know
the earlier problem about this no not
the other problem but the seventh bridge
of konisberg which was resolved you know
solved by
ella which essentially asks you to
figure out if you can you know cross
all the bridge in a certain way
so currently in mathematica you can
actually model this object this is a
graph
and you can use ellerian graphq to
actually to know if the answer is
correct or not
so in two lines you model the object
how you do that
and modeling this object is actually
quite simple is a graph and all i did is
to put the image on the background you
go to wikipedia grab the image
do an ep log of the graph and then you
get it
and you know if you teach your kids this
is actually quite negative and quite
clear you just see that you have the
bridge you have the car
okay so this is essentially what we did
for mix graph a lot of functionality
behind quite powerful
so the next one was essentially also
make
so
3d visualizations
so what we did essentially we
made graph
able to plot in 3d
so that functionality is just purely for
drawing it doesn't affect anything in
terms of computation up to one function
which i will talk probably later on
so let's see how you do that so
essentially if you have a random you
know i will just generate a graph
random graph
10 20.
perfect so that's a random graph it
rendered in 2d
so what we did we introduced a function
we call graph3d
if you take that graph you map it back
you get a 3d representation
you can manipulate it rotate it
compute on it
or you can even project it back in 2d by
just doing graph
on it and in my back
so there's a high fidelity on both sides
and it work
smoothly for
you and all these are just graph objects
you use them as you want
it's a graph
so the fundamental object there is a
graph
the only difference is that this is a
constructor only a constructor we just
set up an option plotted in 3d
so it's just the visualization side
which actually just seems so nothing
nothing different
and actually let's see if it's actually
the case
so as you can imagine to be able to do
that we have to actually
be white but white but
white new you know new algorithm for
each of the layout we have
so i think we have about the a dozen of
layout
from spring electrical to you know basic
circular embedding we have to write 3d
version of those layout
and we actually did that and we support
all of them automatically so as soon as
you do graph 3d
you know if at the reach you know at the
beginning you have a spring electrical
embedding
we run the algorithm but you know in 3d
and then we provide you the
appropriate layout
so that work automatically for you don't
have to do anything or implement
anything else
and actually you know in that whole
phone we actually went further why don't
we do nd
it's always good to generalize so
actually behind the scene you can
actually do the embedding in nd
but unfortunately we can just draw it in
3d so today we actually be able to show
you know how dimension we can do that so
this is a basic example where you take
the hyper cube
and then this kind of show you after
picking you know two different
projection habits
and the function if you want to get you
know
the actually coordinate of your
embedding you you use graph embedding
you know spring electrical and this is a
dimension
you can go to 20 the whole sim algorithm
will kind of scale and automatically do
that for you
so again behind the scene we do all the
functionality you know all the work for
you and everything you just work
smoothly
okay so that was mixed graph
mixed graph multiple graph and this was
3d visualization so this was the you
know the main
big functionality we added under the
wood for you
so
as usual we decided to actually enhance
more fortunately based on suggestion
from different people
so one thing we did is that we
introduced new constructors
and one of the most commonly asked was
spamming tweet
so we have an implementation of spamming
three extremely fast one of the best out
there and it works also for all the type
of graph from weighted graph
to multigraph and such a thing so we
support it globally on the set of
functionality we have
but also what we did is we provided
functionality for graph editing
so if you want to manipulate our editor
graph so vertex contraction which can
contract a set of vertices
and edge contrast as you contact a set
of edges
and link rank here is just
you just have to drop it somewhere but
it fit in the
set of functionality of pagerank
which was assisted to social network
analysis
so the group of functionality also we
added was about pattern cycle so we have
been seeing a lot of requests from users
about
being able to find part beside the
shortest path how can i find 20 parts
you know from you know point a to point
b in my graph
so we introduced fine parts which return
you a
part
between two vertexes you can decide to
find 20 of them a thousand of them or
all of them we generate we found them
and we return them
quite nicely
and it's really fast
but also what we did is that we provided
also some specific functionality about
finding parts so for example we provided
find independent paths where essentially
you can find parts who doesn't intersect
or doesn't share a common vertex a
common edge
essentially
and what we did also we introduced a set
of functionality above connectivity
which also related to parts so
if you can connect the
two vertex
using two different parts it's you know
it's too connected and such a thing so
it's essentially what we did by
providing all the k connectivity
functionality so you can go to the
documentation it's
all those are well documented
there is nice example
good illustration for you to actually
see and try to understand
you know the functionality and when you
need it and when you
can find useful for it to
apply to your work
so the other set of functionality we
decided to introduce was about cycle not
too far from part
so we introduced fine cycle which is
similar to fine parts so essentially
give you all possible cycle too
or a finite number of them
but you know if you do math or you love
math in principle you know that all the
cycle create the
vector space of our finite field of
all the torii around so we kind of
decided to
introduce the appropriate functionality
to actually analyze it so if it's a
vector space that means there is a basis
so we introduce find fundamental cycle
and edge cycle matrix which essentially
represents a sort of basis
each base have a specific property so
essentially it's that
and also what we did is that we enhanced
five short store and i will probably
discuss a little bit later on the
announcement we did for financial testor
but what's good in what was special in
this version is that
it worked on graph it worked on geo
position and it worked on strings as
before but it's more fast and more
efficient and i will show some examples
okay
so the next offset of functionality also
introduces how we enhance essentially is
about fine isomorphism
so before our function finders amorphism
can just find one isomorphism
so currently now we can find all of the
isomorphism you want between two graphs
and also we introduce graphothermorphism
so this is kind of hardcore
graph theory if you are more interested
on that so essentially which gives you
the group of automorphism between two
graphs
and you can actually be doing a lot of
yes
right
oh sorry probably yeah
isomorphism between two two graphs or
two different graphs but yes
automorphism is on the same graph yes
thank you
and by the way if you're interested to
actually see the application and the use
of this you should probably go into talk
of teo i don't know at what time
this i think is tomorrow um
on tiling you will see actually how he
used it to do quilting
and it's quite interesting and quite
beautiful from the use of you know short
test tour to
cycle and such we saw the application he
used how to actually do
quilting
on his mini huge milling machine or such
a thing
okay the other functionality also
introduces canonical graph
so essentially canonical graph use
economical representation of graph so if
to graph is a morpheme the resulting
graph is the same so we also return you
the canonical graph
of a graph so
that's actually and more you know if you
actually have ten thousand graph and you
want to check that the isomorphic
instead of calling find isomorphic on
each of them you can actually just map
canonical graph on them and compare if
the results are the same two graphics
have the same canonical graphic as a
morphe so i mean so if you just take any
graph
right you take
let's take the peterson graph you apply
canonical graph there you get another
graph
the thing is that that graph is unique
in the term that if any graph is
isomorphic
to the peterson graph
then his canonical graph would be the
same as the peterson would have
so let me show you a basic example
so this is the papua's graph
this is canonical graph
so if you build any graph which is
isomorphic to
the purpose graph you'll always get this
same graph
so it's a kind of a unique object
which represents your graph in some way
and one advantage especially if you do
buy you know bioinformatics and such
when you have 10 000 molecule and you
want to actually analyze them
usually what you do is you compute
canonical graph
right
and also it's kind of useful also in
terms of for example um you know we have
graph data which is essentially a
database of graphs
so essentially if you can actually
compute a canonical graph all of all of
them so every time
anyone gave you a graph you just have to
compute this canonical graph and map it
to the database and then you can return
the property of the graph
so that's one way you can actually
extend that proportionality
which also kind of more requested by
eric because you want to build it in
word from alpha where you can give a
random graph and we map it to our
database
so the next set of functionality we
build actually was about relation
between graphs so we introduced
transitive closure
which is now the reachability graph so
if you take a graph you find you you try
to find all the
vertex you can reach from one you know
from one vertex to another one so it's
more reachability and it's quite useful
and also we introduce the convex
operation which is transitive reduction
so what's the smallest graph
such that if you can reach you know one
you know a point to another one will
actually be
correspond to the transitive closure of
that graph
and the last set of functionality we
introduced was about polynomials
which
i don't see
so we introduced total polynomial
chromatic polynomial these are invariant
polynomial for graphs so if two graph
isomorphic have the same
type of polynomials
so this is slightly more hardcore number
three these are the corner way some
people were saying we haven't covered
and we decided to go there and cover
them
so to be just sure that we cover all the
ground for
people to do number three sorry graftory
in the system
so one way to actually show you the
power of this whole system for example
you can build a
generate a maze in three line using
spamming three and you can actually
solve it
and visualize the result
right one vertex missing there
which is just a game of
changing the style and generating the
maze so you can actually build maze and
solve them into mathematica quite easily
the other application
which actually came because we were
working on you know releasing the system
and we had to build some nice page so
that we showed the functionality we end
up you know looking for some nice
application and one of the you know i
was looking at mpr series on power
hungry i don't know how to end up there
and then i saw this network they had so
this picture
and then i just want to kind of produce
it in mathematics and actually try to
analyze if the
power grid in the u.s is robust enough
is it possible so
quite easily i took you know the picture
i copy and paste it do it
image adjusts
and essentially i wanted to do a
morphological
graph on it but also i wanted to map it
on the actual map so that you actually
sees it so i you know i call our
geographic function got the map of the
u.s the continent in america
and then i did a morphological graph
and then i got my network so this is a
graph with the network quite similar
to that one exactly similar actually
so you can actually model in in two line
or three line that's the original
network and now you can actually start
to do analysis you can
figure out you know
what are the subgraphs which one can
sustain
failure
or attack or anything like that so if
you're in that field of
trying to enhance the you know the power
green the u.s entry line you can
actually do that and really analyze the
network
are we just slightly short in terms of
you know we enhance all sort of
performance one of the performance
enhancement was essentially about the
shortest store
you know we added control library to
which is one of the fastest you know
fastest solver for tsp
you have it in mathematic and you can
actually solve the shortest tour
and do some nice animation like this one
essentially we you know we took all the
you know city in the world
and then just you know map find shortest
walk on it and then generate the map
with a nice animate and such
and moreover you can actually do more
interesting things essentially you can
do tsp art
so this is a image of
i believe you're recognized even
you can actually take the position
and since fireshot is throwing so fast
you can actually solve it in a couple of
seconds and
do a continuous line drawing
of the image so let me just resize it
and then you actually see that it's the
same
and you can even do the same for
monalisa which have you know millions of
points
so you take a couple of seconds and then
you start to end
a nice mona lisa you know people spend a
lifetime playing with that and calling
it you know tsp art and generating nice
things but you can do that now in
one or two line in mathematica
right so monalisa is taking some time
so in short we provided you know support
for multi-graph 3d visualization
capability enhancement oh
she came back fantastic
so this is a continuous line of mona
lisa
so
so anyway to conclude you can go to our
marketing page there is good
documentation there you can see the list
of feature page
and if you have any questions you can
ask roger varandi director jbum and jan
in the room so about grappa network so
thank you